bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en esta oportunidad nos acompaña josé
miguel vivanco director ejecutivo para
las américas de la organización human
rights watch para hablar sobre el
informe anual de la organización en el
que se resumen las condiciones de los
derechos humanos en casi 100 países y
territorios en todo el mundo en 2020
señor vivanco gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 le pregunto cuáles
fueron los derechos fundamentales que
más se violaron en el año que pasó
marcado por la pandemia de kobe 19 y
cuáles son los nuevos desafíos que
enfrenta la humanidad en actualidad
mire durante el año pasado y ha sido el
año del cob y se registraron serios
retrocesos en el goce en el respeto a
los derechos y libertades fundamentales
en todo el mundo fue un periodo donde
muchos gobiernos se aprovecharon de la
pandemia para imponer medidas
draconianas de control de control
ciudadano en muchos gobiernos se auto
-un a un enfoque más bien militar o
policial de un problema que es
indudablemente una cuestión de salud
pública de extraordinaria importancia
pero el enfoque fue más bien represivo
sancionatorio
y en ese en ese ámbito hay gobiernos que
aprovecharon la pandemia para
y concentrar el poder para debilitar los
mecanismos de control el poder judicial
a pesar de que muchas veces cuenta con
jueces que están interesados y motivados
a defender los derechos constitucionales
y las libertades públicas usualmente se
mueve con gran lentitud y la pandemia
además ofrece la posibilidad de que los
gobiernos por la emergencia hagan
compras y desembolsos sin mayor
transparencia por decreto
a dedo respecto a aquellos que les
pueden resolver problemas médicos a la
mayor edad y en eso ha habido una enorme
falta de rendición de cuentas y hay
muchas denuncias en todas partes del
mundo no solo por abuso de poder sino
también por corrupción sí señor blanco
ahora dicho todo esto la pandemia hizo
que nos olvidáramos entonces de las
libertades fundamentales y que esta
misma perdiera el valor ante la
necesidad de limitar las con los
confinamientos que hemos vivido
las libertades
no se pierden así nomás y especialmente
el pueblo y los distintos sectores que
son conscientes de del valor que
representa el ejercicio las libertades
públicas las defienden pero cuando hay
instituciones democráticas débiles y
cuando hay caudillos en el poder una de
las libertades que sufre aparte por
supuesto de la de circulación y de
reunión que es obvio que debe ser
restringida cuando se trata de evitar el
contagio pero muchas veces la tentación
de los gobernantes es limitar el
ejercicio de la libertad de expresión
porque la libertad de expresión la que
ejerce a los ciudadanos a la sociedad
civil y los medios de comunicación
líderes independientes y que sirve
precisamente para fiscalizar el
ejercicio del poder especialmente cuando
nos encontramos ante una emergencia de
esta naturaleza y esa libertad
indudablemente que ha sufrido censuras y
ha sufrido retrocesos durante este
periodo ahora entrando un poco más en
materia del informe de solvente en
estado
estuvo marcado por protestas raciales
lideradas por el movimiento black light
matters que piden que sea es el racismo
sistémico en eeuu y también la igualdad
de condiciones para los afroamericanos
además queda un país completamente
paralizado tras cuatro años de la
administración del presidente de donald
trump que retos en materia de derechos
humanos le esperan al nuevo mandatario a
joe byte en enormes enorme hay que
prácticamente reconstruir el tejido
social de un país y lo entrega a trump
profundamente dividido y polarizado
trampa ha sido un desastre para la causa
los derechos humanos porque ha incitado
la violencia porque ha promovido la
causa de grupos de extrema derecha
racistas que creen la superioridad de
ellos sobre el resto del país un
desprecio profundo hacia las minorías
hacia los afroamericanos hacia los
mecanismos de control los medios de
comunicación
realmente
como sabemos es un líder que miente de
una manera sistemática y patológica y
que hasta el día de hoy no reconoce nada
menos que los resultados electorales
donde él fue felizmente derrotado una de
las buenas noticias del año pasado es
precisamente la derrota de trump y el
hecho que a pesar de todas las pataletas
y todos los de las maniobras que ha
inventado ahora las instituciones
judiciales las instituciones
democráticas
han funcionado y están resistiendo lo
que ha sido una avalancha de un líder e
inescrupuloso como éste frank y
obviamente que le entrega el poder a
partir del 20 a un gobierno distinto que
está comprometido con las causas de los
derechos humanos de las libertades
públicas veremos qué es lo que puede
hacer pero
los desafíos son de una magnitud
realmente
y significativa los que tendrán que
enfrentar tanto a nivel interno como a
nivel internacional un gobierno como el
de baile ahora todos vimos con estupor
el asalto al capitolio por parte de los
seguidores del presidente saliente
donald trump qué significado tiene este
suceso para los derechos humanos y para
la democracia de eeuu
bueno es un asalto al lo que simboliza
la democracia en los eeuu un asalto
promovido avalado instigado nada menos
que por famp esto no tiene precedentes
en la historia de los eeuu y realmente
la vejación y que han hecho de la
institucionalidad democrática con el
aval de frank y de muchos de miembros
del partido detrás del partido
republicano ha tenido una
y digamos que ha hecho un gran daño a la
credibilidad las instituciones sobre
todo porque habrá quienes incluso cuando
partan hay unos millones no estoy
pensando los 74 millones que votaron por
él pero sí un buen porcentaje se
seguirán sosteniendo que aquí les
robaron la elección y no hay que
olvidarse nunca que en este país todo el
mundo está armado aquí la segunda
enmienda que protege es el porte de
armas es prácticamente tan sagrada como
la biblia y esos sectores que se
identifican con trump que son muy
recalcitrantes y radicales y reivindican
precisamente el uso de armas si esos
sectores no entienden que las disputas
se dirimen democráticamente y
participando en el sistema electoral se
vienen años muy duros donde puede haber
en brotes de violencia realmente
inéditos en la historia contemporánea
los eeuu hablemos ahora de américa
latina' human right watch también alertó
sobre la grave situación en materia de
derechos humanos que se viven en algunos
países de nuestra región cuáles son los
más críticos los más críticos son las
tres dictaduras que lograron
consolidarse el año el año pasado
me refiero fundamentalmente a venezuela
exclusivamente a venezuela a nicaragua
ya cuba cuba se consolidó así ya hace
muchas décadas es una dictadura militar
que no permite el ejercicio de las
libertades más elementales pero
venezuela y nicaragua lamentablemente se
se han salido con las suyas y maduro
logró eliminar el último reducto
democrático el último bastión que ha
quedado de institución autónoma
independiente del ejecutivo de la
dictadura como es la asamblea
legislativa es una muy lamentable muy
doloroso porque en el caso de venezuela
las relaciones a derechos humanos van
acompañadas de una emergencia
humanitaria de una enorme profundidad
con falta alimentos y medicinas
especialmente para los más pobres qué es
lo que explica por cierto el el éxodo
masivo de venezolanos al resto de la
región y lo lamentable y con esto cierro
es que los gigantes de la región como
son méxico y
y brasil se están liderados por
gobernantes populistas demagogos dos
caudillos que no creen en la
institucionalidad democrática y que
gobiernan como si el país les
perteneciera fuera propiedad privada se
han olvidado e ignoran los mecanismos de
control a pesar de que son personajes
que representan posiciones ideológicas
contrapuestas
son líderes que no defienden las
libertades públicas ni los derechos
fundamentales en la democracia y
entonces éste nos encontramos con una
región a la deriva donde no hay voces
creíbles y fuertes con peso capaces de
defender estos valores señor vivanco ya
para finalizar en un terreno un poco más
positivo que destacaría en materia de
derechos humanos en un año tan atípico
como fue el 2020
primero la derrota de everton aunque
aunque no lo crean esta no es una
posición partidista ni mucho menos creo
que los electores en los eeuu que le
hicieron un gran favor al país a los
eeuu la democracia norteamericana y
también a la humanidad segundo el
surgimiento de un movimiento de
intelectuales y de artistas que están
defendiendo el derecho a la libertad de
expresión en cuba como es el movimiento
san isidro que con las uñas y a pulso
están tratando de abrirse un espacio
contra la censura y lo tercero son las
instituciones democráticas en brasil que
a pesar de bolsonaro a pesar de sus
esfuerzos por concentrar el poder y
avasallar la suprema corte de brasil ha
logrado junto al congreso y a los
gobernadores resistir las peores
iniciativas de bolsón ario especies
especialmente en lo que tiene que ver
con el manejo de la pandemia gracias a
esas instituciones democráticas las
brasileñas es que bolsonaro no ha
logrado hacer el mayor daño a la
democracia
si en este país señor vivanco gracias
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
la entrevista de france 24 hasta una
próxima oportunidad de la josé miguel
vivanco director ejecutivo para las
américas de la organización human right
watch hasta aquí este espacio de la
entrevista hacer una próxima edición
[Música]